MODERATOR: Okay, so whenever you're ready, and you can start that i'm going to start the clock.
MODERATOR: And you can start by reading the first task out loud so, then I can understand where you are more or less.
P9: When you when you asked us to read the documents that text, it means that we should just read the text in front of us in this on this current.
P9: line by line.
MODERATOR: Not only the task so if you go to page four, there are some tasks.
P9: In the task of on it asked us.
P9: To start reading the text.
MODERATOR: Yes, perfect so.
MODERATOR: This is what these are the tasks and then you should be able to complete the tasks with the dashboard.
P9: Okay, I start with SEC SEC, the rating and then doing make it pushing pushing the button on the Santa.
MODERATOR: Yes, it's just you what you would do is you can just talk again i'm going to start the clock Okay, and then you can start with an experiment i'm not gonna say anything I can only say Okay, or like i'm not gonna say anything you should be able to do all the tasks from the dashboard okay.
MODERATOR: Okay perfect and we're starting now.
P9: Okay, see the application.
P9: This dashboard highs the complexities in linking clinical rare disease, they talk with environmental observations using knowledge graphs.
P9: The desired outcome is to support health.
P9: Data researchers identify appropriate environmental variables, to enable the hypothesis exploration in researching rare diseases.
P9: and
P9: We first select and submit the query imposed on the Left panel and then explore.
P9: The environmental data and click submit button.
P9: At the end we export the data.
P9: Okay, the data is a environmental observations a gathered from the sources with air pollution aerosol data.
P9: open.
P9: ocean.
P9: city new tabs.
P9: Okay data density I should.
P9: click the button and over the over the region is to get the number of data so okay so.
P9: it's been studied by this data.
P9: These are.
P9: These are the.
P9: locations that are.
P9: Good.
P9: Let me check fair pool.
P9: Very most of the locations are categorized in.
P9: A good band, because the colors of them are green.
P9: Okay, the light here the green color.
P9: Better that.
MODERATOR: Would you tell me.
MODERATOR: What happens, later on, from.
P9: Did they talk comes from.
P9: here.
P9: quietly.
MODERATOR: Perfect that's what that's that's the perfect.
MODERATOR: Thank you that's what I was asking.
P9: And for historical data.
P9: Data visualization.
MODERATOR: If you can tell me again, where are these data come from that's okay for the task.
P9: And it is about.
P9: historical data from current stations historical data that.
P9: Is our climate data card.
P9: And everyone.
P9: It is just the explanation.
P9: To MIT explanations about the project.
MODERATOR: Perfect Thank you very much.
P9: you're welcome now I should.
P9: Open up.
P9: Here I should select some.
P9: Some pillar hello, I location location location of interest.
P9: Which clarity I should consider to have more data yes.
MODERATOR: Up to you do you just hover up Do you know what what it means.
P9: Yes, I Homer now leads.
MODERATOR: to hover on the map.
MODERATOR: That you see.
P9: Here I don't know how to choose any any location.
P9: If I.
MODERATOR: can access management were you saying you want me to say mentioned what you see that's it no problem.
P9: steam inches, but when I want to.
P9: Choose eat I cannot choose it.
P9: Or if I want to.
P9: One like Newcastle.
P9: not think I can I.
P9: I hardly can control them.
Okay.
P9: And then maybe I do something, some mistakes in choosing them.
MODERATOR: it's fine it's fine you can go on.
P9: Okay, we continue to.
P9: The Left panel.
P9: and choose.
P9: and create a query.
P9: task to.
P9: Our uncle vasculitis a land event of interest.
P9: The interest.
P9: For failure, please choose high probability location of Internet, for example by I choose.
P9: I choose, there are three options.
P9: I choose says, Carlo.
P9: And the yes for the data.
P9: 2017.
P9: and
P9: Oh no if I.
P9: Go yeah yes, there are several auction toppling Okay, there are seven pages or options, maybe I better choose blank, for I choose the LIFE before which is more up to date 2009.
P9: location of intelligence.
P9: So.
P9: I.
P9: I time.
P9: I think my computer.
MODERATOR: And sorry to smoke like.
It.
P9: Is.
P9: So it is for the she's in our land.
P9: Then.
P9: start date.
P9: I don't I should is it optional or other tissues to start now choice.
P9: But data sources submit.
P9: submit for not, I think, is not activated so let's choose a start date for example 2009.
P9: The year.
P9: From 2020 not 2000 and.
P9: So, then, the date for like for these 2019 and month seven.
MODERATOR: I wanted to say that, for this experiment, I only have 2020 data, because there was too much later he was too slow.
MODERATOR: Imagine that long for these 2020 and then conduct experiments.
P9: Okay, he is john okay.
P9: johnny's month seven.
P9: No, no john is mistakes.
P9: I bet, for a start date here I should choose a start date and end date right.
MODERATOR: 2020 because I only have data for 2020 I forgot to say it in some of the beginning.
MODERATOR: So there's only 2028 so imagine long for his 2020.
Okay.
P9: Okay, if you start from February.
P9: Can you can you choose that data which is which comes after.
MODERATOR: Yes.
P9: Okay, for one mind.
P9: And then data sources.
P9: And tempura you need sippy saying monthly day.
P9: And discussion special tempura.
P9: aggregations choose me.
P9: And then submit for.
P9: This is the quarterback.
MODERATOR: Okay.
P9: Okay, give me to.
P9: Open querying.
P9: Option options rare disease uncovers qualitatively, he is hyper Okay, these are the options that I chose, and yes, the sub tabs of data time, since this is the information of the tall or okay.
P9: When there is when when it says that the sun is a point one.
P9: I don't understand what does this mean.
P9: The full name of the barrier.
P9: With the your needs that Pierre.
P9: have been hovering Okay, think of it here sunshine duration.
P9: OK duration sunshine duration pair day.
P9: it's minutes Hello.
P9: Okay, and then.
P9: for further information.
P9: and talking college.
P9: me see time series.
MODERATOR: finish the task as we move into a time series place.
P9: here.
P9: He wanted me to export something.
MODERATOR: Can you explain me the colors that you see in the table, for example.
P9: Yes, there are red color.
P9: In the table.
P9: I don't I don't know what does this.
MODERATOR: Maybe.
MODERATOR: You will not read this task again.
MODERATOR: You might you might miss something.
P9: Yes.
P9: Tasks.
P9: I cannot access to my computer.
P9: Okay, good.
P9: here.
P9: and talk to the interpretation of the.
P9: background colors okay talk to have the data table the columns that you want to display Okay, not a vertical.
P9: Let me see.
P9: For example, here in rain corner, there is one red.
P9: One red.
P9: Value background and which is the maximum number.
P9: Of this column.
P9: And for me is.
P9: Also it chooses 10,034 I can say that it is also the maximum number.
P9: Here the guru partners, which should be should indicated.
P9: The lower the minimum number of each column.
P9: I think so, yes, I think it is.
P9: America America.
MODERATOR: But if you go to like you missed one button on the top that maybe has explanation for it on the top of this.
P9: Human toggle.
MODERATOR: know you go on the top.
P9: And here, there is another open color table description.
P9: If the data if data is normally distributed.
P9: 95% should be between my minus two.
P9: plus two.
P9: Values greater than two are high, and they are read by values.
P9: Less than minus two are low and below so here.
P9: 5.6 is not this down to minus two but it isn't it is blue.
P9: and
P9: Yes, I don't understand why.
P9: It is N minus two but in none of them are lower than minus two.
MODERATOR: Okay it's fine go go ahead with the phone that's good.
P9: Okay, so I should now.
P9: If I want to save something.
P9: I choose some.
P9: temperature.
MODERATOR: OK.
P9: OK.
P9: Now, I chose these things, and then.
P9: push for.
MODERATOR: you're exporting it to my computer the chest.
P9: But you were exporting yes okay.
P9: I should do.
P9: is to check for the time series.
P9: Right.
MODERATOR: You have the next task task for.
P9: US for.
MODERATOR: My computer, let me one second.
MODERATOR: You can open the PDF I don't know how you did last time.
P9: Yes, I can I could choose.
P9: yeah but no, I have no access to I just remember that.
MODERATOR: Let me stop sharing.
MODERATOR: yeah I can make, can you put us out top.
MODERATOR: Maybe it works.
P9: No, no, it doesn't work.
MODERATOR: And you cannot do, can you click somewhere else in the screen because they cannot get control back.
P9: How can I.
MODERATOR: You know.
P9: I am controlling your escape.
P9: Exit.
MODERATOR: Okay, no, no, you can.
P9: Okay, yes.
P9: task for.
P9: Expert or the other tabs beside that data which are clearly products Okay, and then.
P9: I should say about this useful.
P9: So here.
MODERATOR: I give you control the computer.
Okay.
P9: Thank you, and now if we check for.
P9: The time series of the data.
P9: This is.
P9: This is temperature okay very nice I know now which day has morning dish day how the temperature increases or decreases there is no routine in and none of them Okay, and then about parts.
MODERATOR: When you want to read the text in this.
P9: OK, this visualization time series.
P9: visual history long time this specializations interactive for the law.
P9: We can some on top or other.
P9: Can download as PNG even we can save the plot for legend at the ride the collective valuable and select.
P9: or Double Click to say, for example, if I selected rain, it gives me the box.
P9: Okay.
MODERATOR: How can I work.
MODERATOR: I think there was a.
MODERATOR: There was a bit of a delay you.
MODERATOR: know you can try to click again.
P9: For example, in temperature.
P9: Then I click man's.
P9: He says click the barrier to select and Double Click to select only.
P9: Okay, this is the only value and then.
MODERATOR: This, for me.
MODERATOR: This these are under the water.
P9: And then.
P9: Okay, Nice.
P9: And then poor range is slide there.
P9: This ranges like Kelly can direct the selectivity.
P9: lot.
P9: But this ranges like there.
P9: Is here.
P9: A from a.
P9: 20.
P9: minutes go to either.
P9: This.
P9: This is the.
P9: temperature.
P9: Okay, and all of them are in the same corner.
P9: Then.
P9: We can also save the clock in solar cloud.
P9: Is the radius length indicates the wind dissipate and the degrees of the wind direction this visual is interactive or so.
P9: Okay, but if you do not have or not we should choose.
P9: me to.
P9: This is for wine dependence.
P9: Complex variable wine dependencies, for example.
P9: temperature.
P9: Okay.
P9: What are these colors.
P9: And I don't know what this.
P9: But.
P9: For each point man I gotta.
P9: Let me, let me when I got there and.
P9: When I saw on the update for each point, it gives me the information, for example, temperature.
P9: wt is Peter videotape Dr, although I don't know what are these.
P9: Information, but it is very informative yes.
MODERATOR: Okay perfect.
P9: This is query on time.
MODERATOR: Yes or no, you can move to task.
P9: task five but is that, in short.
MODERATOR: And not task five and the next tasks so tasks number fights in a PDF document.
P9: notorious query to end quality.
Okay.
P9: Okay, I should create two other queries and submit them that's it.
MODERATOR: And then i'm going to give you control or you can even go.
P9: Stop this query this is query one tab I don't want it anymore, but I keep it open, but if I check on parity no icon to.
P9: create a new query.
P9: It means that you should choose and co vasculitis here land here I choose for.
P9: North.
P9: And again from the same block for.
P9: long for the data range that, for example, again, the same day, which is in.
P9: In February.
P9: T.
P9: Data source.
P9: Now, generating computer.
P9: Yes, it's done and, at the same time I.
P9: choose another.
P9: query.
P9: Please, the event of interest should be.
P9: should be.
P9: This time I.
P9: choose the.
P9: policy.
P9: And they came the same information, but here like for.
P9: There is not the same.
P9: And then here at.
P9: This is for.
P9: test, so I choose.
P9: Okay, now I can compare.
P9: The quick.
P9: In comparative.
P9: query data previously submitted in this lesson can be conquered by specific by you can combine these queries into groups with the multiple selection inputs.
P9: Because, all of them are langford I love to group all three together into a potential increase the signal to noise ratio decide the number of course that you wish to compare selected which careers, you want to.
P9: explore issues environmental the different class.
P9: to generate coral reefs number of columns here I should choose, for example.
P9: So groups know.
P9: There are two different vasculitis possible high probability and.
P9: No.
P9: One Q.
P9: guru to.
P9: guru TV.
P9: Okay now.
P9: groups.
P9: I should choose, for example.
P9: It says mean for coral bit below.
P9: This is high probability best qualities here.
P9: too, they are they haven't they are, they have no filler and here.
P9: They are possible.
P9: This is the day.
P9: Okay.
P9: Oh.
P9: For example, for temperature.
P9: I see.
P9: The ranges are different.
P9: books.
P9: The temperature.
P9: For example, here in the temperature box lot shows us that this affects the this guru.
P9: And the divine spirit of temperature should be in this range for go to, for example, to affect that like this, you can interpret.
P9: distribution.
P9: Okay, for one, it doesn't show anything, it means that.
P9: A patient does not affect anything on colo plan, but if I choose rain for time series for coral.
P9: It has the painted a small part, yes or no, it is temperature, let me choose rain again for this days.
P9: Yes, it is also a sniper.
P9: And bugs a lot of.
bugs.
P9: There is something.
P9: For this doesn't show anything, what does this mean we do not have any distribution for.
P9: Right.
P9: Okay that's a.
P9: task.
P9: We compare different queries.
P9: And now.
P9: Okay, you should do.
P9: is to export the results we obtained.
P9: And finally.
P9: I should, I should tell about my.
P9: Experience on doing this.
P9: I think it was fun.
MODERATOR: We want to explore first do the tasks.
P9: to export the tasks I go to home.
P9: No.
P9: Export button.
P9: check.
P9: Okay.
P9: I should choose the.
P9: Is the export, but I wanted to export the comparative results, there is no export button.
MODERATOR: OK.
P9: OK.
P9: that's it finished.
MODERATOR: Do you want to finish the task what it says, open to see don't load up.
P9: For download.
P9: This computer I don't know.
P9: download your mean this button.
P9: queries the tape download see fit all data tables.
P9: downloaded in local folder name advice.
MODERATOR: Okay perfect.
MODERATOR: Perfect Thank you.
P9: you're welcome.
MODERATOR: To the last sentence.
P9: Okay.
P9: We should.
P9: summarize where.
P9: My overall experience completing this test, and do you think this is see the dashboard.
P9: And then completed PS Su Pew question okay I it was really fun experiment and I enjoyed it was.
P9: shorter than I expected, because it was easy to learn what to do with it.
P9: And the view the view of the dashboard is very beautiful the colors are.
P9: I like the colors I mean the tone of colors is good for our eyes and then.
P9: Some maybe because I use I use you normally a single and glasses, it was really a bit.
P9: difficult to read them.
Okay.
P9: Okay.
MODERATOR: Okay.
MODERATOR: Perfect Thank you very much.
P9: Thank you.
MODERATOR: i'm going to start the in.
MODERATOR: The control i'm going to stop the.
MODERATOR: And when I stop the recording.